going out to uh
pennsylvania i'm gonna have a
conversation there with dave dave good
afternoon how can
dr d and i serve hey good afternoon
how are you guys doing today doing good
doing good man thanks for calling in how
can we help
so i got a relationship question which i
think
mr deloney would be able to help me out
a lot with this one um
i have a bit of financial uh background
i just wanted to
i'm going through the process myself of
going to uh using every dollar budgeting
and uh
going through my own finances working
the debt snowball i'm still on uh
step two i paid off two credit cards and
such and i'm trying to work this out
with family members as i go along
uh the process and along with that i'm
also trying to help my girlfriend
through it
um so recently she with covet and
everything you know
she has been going through a lot of jobs
she's actually been through
about seven jobs throughout the last
year uh can't
consistently hold her a job and
basically she had a moment the other
night where she broke down because of
her finances
and you know i tried to tell her i said
you know this is why i'm doing what i'm
doing and
i think we need to do this with you as
well and she
um she thinks that the you know not as
she doesn't want to do the plan she
wants to do what she wants to do she's
the
the free thinker and i'm the one who's
more of the budgeter and who likes to
conserve my money hey dave why can't she
hold down a job
um i i honestly think it's just
for preference she doesn't like retail
she doesn't like anything
so she's not showing up to work is she
showing up late does she just quit after
a couple of days
she she just quits after a couple days
and you know
it came down to a point where all her
bills became
um outstanding and yeah that's what
happens when you quit your job
your bills don't get paid right right
and
she had her insurance uh cancelled her
policies and stuff like that and
yeah they want to get paid too yeah yeah
she looked to me and said
you know why you know i told you my
situation why haven't you helped me more
than you already have
i told her i'm like i'm trying to help
you through the process of learning to
be an adult yourself and trying to
take care of your family finances
yourself um
she didn't like that answer she was like
why didn't you help me pay through these
things while
you know i was going through troubles
but to me i felt like
the fact that it was her choice to not
continue working through her jobs and
stuff like that that it shouldn't be an
obligation for me to pay her bills
and uh she sees otherwise so so
what man there's a lot here we can spend
a couple of weeks with this one
um what's your what's your question
um should i have done more to help her
through
this time when she was going to go be be
delinquent in her finances and stuff
even though i'm still working through my
process myself as well
yeah dave so here's the deal the answer
you gave her
is the answer a dad gives a child
you are not her father and um
your job is to be her boyfriend man and
so the the answer
you are not in a position to be teaching
her adult responsibility which is how
you put it right
you need to learn how to being a
responsible adult man that's not your
job
your job as a boyfriend is to love her
and support her
now no you shouldn't be paying her bills
when she chooses to go through seven
jobs in six months and she chooses to
not like
certain jobs the reality is if dave
fired me today my bills still
need to be paid at the end of the month
and that means as a responsible adult
i will be on the street i'll give myself
24 hours and then i'm not hitting the
street
the next day looking for pizza delivery
jobs
and whatever i can scrounge up
to pay my bills for my wife and my
family and my wife is probably going to
hit the street too
and go find a job right because that's
what responsible adults do when things
fall apart
so no your job is not to quote unquote
support her
um by paying her bills or stepping in
when she quits another job or another
job in another job
the reality is man this sounds like a
messy situation it sounds like a
situation that's
um she's got bigger fish to fry than
than the work thing she's got things on
her heart she's got things that she
needs to go meet with somebody about
um and the reality is dude you can't
solve these problems
i always fall back uh on this on this
idea that
people are not puzzles to be solved they
are people to be
with yeah right and so if your
girlfriend is looking for you to fix her
man she's not a machine if she is
looking for you to solve her
she's not a puzzle right and so
you need to step back and say is this
the person i want to be with for a while
is this the person
that um i want to continue to move
forward and closer with in a
relationship and if so
man y'all need some professional
counseling you'll need some relationship
care and she needs to man to be honest
with you to grow up
and face the real world which means
she's gotta go get a job she's gotta
hold the job
especially during a pandemic if she
finds work she's gotta crank it out
and she probably needs to go sit with
somebody with a professional counselor
with a pastor
with a mentor who will be honest with
her because she's got some stuff she's
gotta work through brother and that's
not your baggage to carry
you know dave i i i want to say this no
you're not
oh dave dave i thought you're calling me
dave ramsey okay dave from pennsylvania
yeah yeah
gotcha oh yeah dave i i like your heart
let me say that i believe your heart is
in a good place
i hope you listen to the wisdom of what
john just gave you
i don't want you to lose your heart i
don't want you to lose
your heart to to want to help your your
loved one save that for your spouse
for a girlfriend um be the man
lead by an example if she's upset with
you because you weren't willing to pay
her bills
that's fine give her give her the give
her the door that she can exit
okay if she wants to leave because you
won't pay her bills
then that was never your your situation
at all
if she stays tell her listen we're gonna
both grow together
we we're gonna get we're gonna become
good stewards with our money
i'm not paying your bills you're not
paying my bills and we're gonna grow
together
to one day hopefully be married but if
you're looking for
a man to pay your bills go get you a boy
in a grown man's body
because a real man doesn't pay his
girlfriend's bills
a real man protects and waits until he
is
married to provide for the family but a
boy would try to impress
a girl so i love your heart keep that
heart
keep your mind but save that for your
spouse